In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 8, on which we commemorate the recovery of
the relics of the Holy Great Martyr Theodore, the commander.
On the 8th of the month, we celebrate the translation of the relics of the Holy and Great Martyr Theodore
Stratilatis.
During the time after his glorious martyrdom, the relics of St Theodore were transferred from
Heraklia to Yukaita, where they were placed in the Saint's family home in conformity with
the instructions he had left with his secretary, Aguados, before his death.
There they worked numerous miracles so that the town, afterwards, took the name of Theodoropolis.
It is the translation of these relics that we celebrate today.
Saint Athanasius of Sinai recounts that in Karsat, near Damascus, there existed a church dedicated
to St Theodore Stratilatis where sericines were living in with their wives and children
when Damascus was taken.
One of them shot an arrow at a fresco representing the saint, and immediately fresh blood ran
from the saint's face.
Sometime later, all the sericines in the church were killed.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and
save us.